i'm trevor shonk i'm a kennedy county
councillor member for ramsgate my name's
heather keane and i'm the councillor or
one of the councillors in cliftonville
westward my name is kerry boyd and i
cover garland ward i'm councillor ruth
bailey and i represent viking ward in
broadstairs yeah i'm councillor horis
schrub and i represent cliftonville east
my name is cancer george cupp i'm the
cabinet member for community safety and
youth engagement and i represent burst
and south on the tandem gesture council
[Music]
i wanted to become a counselor because i
wanted to have a better representation
within that so i looked at the
representation that there already was
and felt that there wasn't anyone that
really i could relate to and i think
it's important that if you have people
that are making decisions
and the public can relate to them so for
me i was like i couldn't really see many
young people certainly couldn't see many
young females
and so yeah i guess it was more about
better representation because i've
always been really interested in local
democracy and people having a say
and so actually being the representative
for people in a ward just really
appealed to me to sort of give the local
voice to it i've lived in birchtoon all
of my life and wanted to really be able
to give back to the people that i've
lived around in the community that i've
loved to live in and wanted to try and
make a difference
and i thought that a lot of the
decisions that were being made
would um be possibly a benefit if
younger people were involved with that i
worked a lot in the community anyway um
with various
various different groups organizations
and
i just thought it was the next step i
used to come to a lot of council
meetings too and uh and watch those and
um i just got interested in the politics
and local politics and um i just thought
it was the next step for me just make a
difference really
instead of sitting back moaning and i do
my own because on that age
uh i tried to listen to everybody's
views it was my first time i'd never
done anything like this before
so i was just quite interested really to
find out more about it and having found
out more about it then i put myself
forward so yeah
[Music]